Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel.
In the video today, we’re looking at who
the original Tom was in the expression “Peeping
Tom”
The phrase “peeping Tom” first appeared
in the accounts for the English city of Coventry
in 1773.
Specifically, the accounts note that the city
had recently purchased a wig and paint for
an oak effigy of “Peeping Tom”, using
money from the town’s coffers.
So who was this effigy of?
No real person.
“Peeping Tom” is an iconic part of a legend
surrounding a real person from the 11th Century
called Lady Godiva.
This legend states that Lady Godiva once rode
through the city’s streets on horseback,
totally naked, in protest of her husband’s
unfair taxation of the populace.
While exact circumstances surrounding this
now mythical ride change depending on which
source you consult, the general story is that
Lady Godiva asked her husband on behalf of
the town to lower taxes.
Her husband, knowing his wife's chaste nature,
joked that he would lower taxes if she agreed
to ride naked through the streets.
Lady Godiva, much to the surprise of her husband,
accepted this offer and appealed to the townspeople
to avert their gaze as she did the deed.
The Lady being popular with her subjects,
unlike her husband, the townspeople dutifully
locked their windows and doors and Lady Godiva
rode proudly through the streets atop a white
stallion with only her long, flowing locks
covering her more sensitive regions.
She then returned to her husband, he, true
to his word, lowered taxes for the town.
While Lady Godiva (meaning "Gift of God")
and her husband, the enormously wealthy Leofric,
Earl of Mercia, most certainly did exist,
as you’ve probably guessed even without
supporting facts, historians are in near universal
agreement that this ride never happened.
To begin with, the first known reference to
the famous ride appeared some two centuries
after the Lady in question died, first mentioned
in the book, Flowers of History written by
one, Roger of Wendover.
Although Roger claimed to have gleaned the
contents of his book from, to quote, the “books
of catholic writers worthy of credit”, his
version of the legend of Lady Godiva’s ride,
which featured knights flanking her and a
gathered crowd, rather than people boarding
up their windows and letting the Lady pass
in peace, is considered to be nothing more
than a fabrication of an unsourced anecdote
that survived from Lady Godiva’s lifetime.
Over the years, this story was taken as fact,
and numerous embellishments were added, leading
to the versions we know today.
Where exactly the legend of this ride came
from is even more perplexing given that, according
to every contemporary source from her time,
Lady Godiva and her husband, Leofric, were
notable philanthropists who frequently gave
money, gold and even buildings to the church,
and once even paid for the building of a monastery
in Coventry.
Another factor that confuses historians about
the origin of the legend of Godiva’s naked
ride is the fact that, as noted in The Domesday
Book of 1086 (a comprehensive record of most
every notable person in England and their
holdings, written likely within a decade of
the Lady's death), Lady Godiva was in her
lifetime one of the few women in the entire
country to be a landowner, controlling a number
of large estates around Coventry and the surrounding
area.
This makes it highly unlikely that she would
have needed to appeal to her husband to lower
taxes as she owned much of the city, and thus
would have been the person responsible for
setting taxes in Coventry, not her husband.
So where does Peeping Tom come into this?
Well the short answer is that he doesn’t,
or at least he didn’t until sometime around
the 17th or 18th century.
The legend of Godiva’s ride remained basically
the same as the one previously mentioned until
around the 1700s, when some versions began
mentioning a man, eventually named Tom.
According to these newer versions of the legend,
while nearly every townsperson dutifully complied
with Lady Godiva’s wishes to avert their
eyes as she rode through the town, "Tom the
tailor" couldn’t resist catching a glimpse
of the Lady in the buff and so drilled a hole
in his shutters to watch her ride by.
Tom’s fate differs depending on the version
of the legend you read, but most claim that
he was either killed or blinded.
The reasons for either eventuality range from
Tom being struck blind by Godiva’s beauty,
killed by God for ignoring Godiva’s request
(the Lady in question being explicitly named
as "beloved by God" in the earliest forms
of the legend), or simply being beaten half
to death and blinded by the rest of the townspeople
when they found out.
Either way, Tom is a modern embellishment
of a story of the legend, with no mention
of him in any version of the legend for nearly
a half a millennium after its creation.
Another thing pointing to "Tom", at least
as a named character, being a relatively modern
invention is that the name, “Thomas”,
is not Anglo Saxon.
"Tom" was, however, a common moniker for a
generic man since around the 15th or 16th
century in England, which is likely why this
particular character was eventually given
this name.
(The first documented instance of the character
being called Tom didn't occur until June 11,
1773, when the Coventry annals mention the
aforementioned wig and paint for the character's
effigy.)
In any event, in the late 17th century, the
people of Coventry began reenacting the Lady's
ride as an annual town event.
The Godiva Procession has been happening in
the town since around 1677 or 1678 and is
still celebrated, albeit sporadically, today.
It generally involves an actress riding through
the town on horseback, sometimes naked, sometimes
not, depending on the sensibilities of the
time.
Unlike in the legend, the people of Coventry
gleefully watch and celebrate the ride.
Within about a half century of the start of
the Godiva Procession tradition (with the
exact date unknown), the people of the town
created the aforementioned effigy of Tom,
which still exists today, giving us our first
definitive mentions of the character.
One potential origin story for the character
of Tom has been suggested via the journals
of three soldiers who visited Coventry in
the early 17th century.
They explicitly note the story of Lady Godiva's
ride and also mention her hair, which is covering
her breasts and mid-section, offending "wantons
glancing Eye".
From the text, it isn't clear whether they
are referring to a peeping Tom figure when
mentioning "wanton" or Leofric himself.
If the former, this would be the first known
reference to a peeping Tom in the story.
Importantly, they also mention seeing a painting
of Lady Godiva's ride which is thought to
be a 1586 work that shows a man in a window
looking down upon the nude Lady as she rode.
(This man's presence in the painting was only
re-discovered in 1976 after the painting was
cleaned and he once again became visible.)
The soldiers, and others from this time, may
well have mistook this man for being a random
"peeping Tom", when in fact the man shown
is Leofric himself, observing his wife's lonely
procession from a window.
Whatever the case, over the years, the phrase
“peeping Tom” became synonymous with the
act of watching someone without their knowledge,
as well as another way to call someone a pervert.
The phrase was first defined in the Classical
Dictionary of the Vulgar Tongue written in
1796 as: “A nick name for a curious prying
fellow.”
So there you have it, Peeping Tom wasn’t
a real person, but a 17th century legend attached
to a legend about an 11th century noblewoman
that, despite having no basis in fact, persists
today in popular culture because it involves
a famous woman who rumor had it got naked
in public.
Apparently people back then weren’t so different
than today, eh?